خميس شكرا
الى وليد العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره في
القدس اللي يطلعنا على اخر النتائج التي
ظهرت
نتائج العينات الثلاث التي نقلتها قنوات
التلفزه الرئيسيه في اسرائيل تؤكد ان
الانتخابات
حيث يتراوح ما سيحصل عليه معذكره الذي يضم
حزب اليهود وهمم
الصهيونيه الدينيه والحزبين المتدينين
متزامتين شاس ويهدودها التراث على مقاعد
تتراوح بين 61 و62 وما عددا وهذا يشير الى
ان الانتخابات اذا تحققت هذه النتيجه قد
تكون قد حسمت في صالح نتنياهو ان عودته
لتراء الحكومه سادسه بتاريخها همم اصبحت
قريبه حزب نتنياه او اللي يكون حصل على
ثلاثين مقعدا وحزب اسرائيل حزب يوجد
مستقبل همم زعامه الرئيس الحكومه الحالي
لبيد اعطته اربعه 24
ماشي يقوده الثنائي اسمه تريتش وبنجبير
وهذا الحزب اعطته العينات بين 14 الى 15
مقعدا اما الاحزاب الاخرى التي تجاوزت
نسبه الحزم فهي كذلك بالاحزاب العربيه
الجبهه والعربيه للتغيير حصلت على اربعه
والقائمه العربيه الموحده هي الاخرى حصلت
على اربعه بينما على حافه تجاوز نسبه
الحسم لكنه لم يتجاوزها حتى هذه الساعه
نحن نتحدث عن عينات انتخابيه كذلك الحال
بالنسبه
لاحزاب اليسار احزاب اليسار العمل اعطته
بين خمسه وسته مقاعد وتحالف ميرسي بين
اربعه وخمسه مقاعد واسرائيل بيتنا لبرمان
ايضا حصل على بين اربعه لخمسه مقاعد بينما
احزاب اليمين واقصاء اليمين كما ذكرنا
اللي كود لزعامه ثانيه او ثلاثين مقعدا
وحزب نونيه الدينيه 14 مقاعد ويهدودها
تراث سبعه مقاعد وحصلت شاس ايضا على بين
سبعه الى ثمانيه مقاعد لكن واضح بان
النتيجه اذا تحققت على هذا الحال فهي
محسومه لصالح نتنياه وحزبه ومعسكره ومعسكر
اليمين واليمن الفاسي الذي سيشكل الائتلاف
الحكومي دون ان يحتاج لاي من الاحزاب
الاخرى التي تقع يمين الوسط وفي الوسط
اذا سنعود اليك مره اخرى ووليد حينما تظهر
نتائج عينات اخرى اذا كانت هنالك عينات
اخرى ستظهر همم
لكن نتوجه الان الى بقيه مراسلينا ورحب
بالياسك الرام في مقر حزب الكود نجوى
السمري في مقر حزب يوجد مستقبل وايضا جبال
البديري في الناصره حيث الاحزاب العربيه
واكبر مدينه عربيه في داخل الخط الاخضر
ابدا بك الياس والاجواء
الاجواء لديك الياس في مقر حزب الكود
انا الحياه
مقر حمله النقود وفي معسكر اليمين بعد
ساعات من الخمول وغياب مظاهر الاحتفال على
غير العاده همم مقر الحمله هنا في القدس
الغربيه كان حاليا حتى الدقائق الاخيره من
ظهور قبل ظهور نتائج العينات التلفزيونيه
لكن الان بدات الحياه همم تعود من جديد
وتنبض من جديد في مقر الحمله مع ظهور
نتائج العينات التليفزيونيه وهي الاهم
التي تتنبا ربما النتائج الحقيقيه
والرسميه في قادم الساعات وفي قادم الايام
ومن الواضح بان معظم العينات التلفزيونيه
الاحياديه المحايده غير المحسوبه لا اعلم
معسكر التغيير ولا اعلم معسكر اليمين تظهر
بان بنيامين يتنياهو ومعسكره نجح في تخطي
نسبه همم او عدد المقاعد المطلوب من اجل
تحقيق اغلبيه النيابيه بعض العينه تعطي
بنيامين نتنياهو61 مقعدا من اصل 120 وبعض
العينات الاخرى تعطيه فوزا
معززا اكثر واقوى باثنين وستين مقعدا وهذه
العينات اذا ما صحت واستقرت عليها ال- ال-
النتائج الرسميه هذا يعني ان معسكر
بنيامين نتنياهو لن يتراجع بمعنى انه لا
يوجد هنالك خطر مع بدايه ظهور النتائج
الرسميه في الساعات القليله المقبله بان
يتراجع معسكر بنيامين يتنياهو لينخفض مثلا
الى 60 مقعدا او الى 59 معتقدا ذلك كان
نتائج العينات تقربه اكثر الى المقعد
الاثنين والستين الاصلي 120 وهذا يعني ان
نتنياهو عائد الى السلطه بقوه على راسي
حكومه يمينيه دينيه اصوليه متجدده يقول
المراقبون هنا في اسرائيل بانها ستكون
الاكثر تطرفا اييه في تاريخ اسرائيل هذا
كان لافتا بان بنيامين نتنياهو رغم
الاستنزاف الكبير في في معسكرته انما حافظ
على قوه حزمه ك همم القوه الاكبر واكبر
الاحزاب في معسكر اليمين وعلى الصعيد كافه
الاحزاب في اسرائيل قصدي 30 فقط بطبيعه
الحال المفاجاه الكبرى هي ليمين الاشد
التطرفا الذي يوصف باليمين الفاشل في
اسرائيل الذي نجح في حصد بين ما بين 14
مقعد الى خمسه 10 مقعدا لبنيين الدنيا كما
اراد
يمينيه اصليه دينيه مستقره بامكانها ان
تحكم اسرائيل لاربعه سنوات ااه متتاليه
وهذا ما تظهره بالفعل نتائج نتائج
ما تصيب النتيجه الرسميه والنتائج الرسميه
طبعا الياس نتوجه الى نجوان سمري في مقر
حزب يوجد مستقبل حزب الابيض رئيس الحكومه
الحاليه كيف انعكست هذه النتائج الاوليه
للعينات التلفزيونيه على الاجواء لديك في
مقر حزب يوجد مستقبل هل يشعرون فعلا انهم
خسروا الانتخابات
الانتظار الى حين صدور نتائج نهائيه رسميه
مع التجديد على انه في بعض الاحيان يكون
هناك
للخطا في هذه النتائج لعينات التلفزه
الاسرائيليه لكن مع ذلك كافه
القنوات التلفزه الاسرائيليه الرسميه
الرئيسيه تمنح هذا الحزب يوجد مستقبل بحسب
نتائج العينات اقل بثلاث الى اربع مقاعد
من مكانك تظهره نتائج استطلاعات الراي
الاخيره والمتتاليه التي بعض منها منح هذا
يوجد مستقبل 27 انه كان يقترب كثيرا من
حزب الكود ولكن الان الفجوه تكبر مع هذه
النتائج ويبدا بطبيعه الحال ايه تكون هناك
صعوبه بالغه في الاقتراب حتى من الاغلبيه
النيابيه ل همم لامكانيه تشكيل ائتلاف
حكومي ايه اصلا هناك مشكله اخرى كانت
تواجه هذا الحزب حتى وان نجح نجح في
الحصول على ائتلاف حكومي من 61 نائبا من
الاحزاب الصغيره الاخرى التي تنضوي تحتم
عسكره الا انه
يتكرر السيناريو السابق في انفراط عقد هذه
الحكومه لانها تجمع العديد من الاحزاب غير
المتجانسه سياسيا وعقائديا وهذا ايضا كان
يتوقع ان يواجه هذه الحكومه مره اخرى لكن
بطبيعه الحال من الواضح ان في حال صدقه
هذه النتائج بشكل كبير اسرائيل تتوجه الى
مكان اخر
كان مختلف اكثر تطرفا مع بروز او وصول حزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه الذي كان يحظى ب سته
مقاعد فقط وحاليا يصل بحسب هذه النتائج
الى 15 مقعدا القوه الثالثه في
الكنيسه همم عدد كبير جدا من المقاعد تحصل
عليه هذه الاحزاب المتشدده اليمنيه
المتطرفه بزعامه موترتش وبنكير هذا التوجه
العنصري الذي يقوده بنك سواء كان ضد
الفلسطينيين ضد العرب بشكل عام يبدو انه
يلاقي صدى وروجا في الشارع الاسرائيلي
طيله هذا اليوم ونحن في تل ابيب في محيط
بعد مراكز الاقتراع في كنا نسمع بالذات
عندما كنا نتحدث اللغه العربيه همم من همم
يعني اسرائيليين تواجدوا في الموقع انهم
يؤيدون ذلك في هذا يقول الكثير وكانهم
ينتخبون بينج فير خصيصا ضد الفلسطينيين
وهذا ربما
يدل على سياسه جديده قد تشهدها اسرائيل
انا لا اقول بان السياسه القديمه اقل ربما
يعني يمينيه ولكن مع ذلك من الواضح ان
التوجه الذي يتبناه بين كبير هو اكثر
تشددا اكثر تطرفا واكثر يمينيه وهو بالذات
يطالب به وزاره في نهايه الحساسيه هي
وزاره الامن الداخلي انه يريد ان يصبح
وزيرا للشرطه الاسرائيليه وقد وعد بنيامين
نتنياه بانه من خلال هذا المنصب ايضا
سيسعى الى الغاء محاكمه نتنياهو بصفته
رئيس للحكومه في حال تمكن من تشكيل هذه
الحكومه زين
معنى الاجواء سمري من مقر حزب يوجد مستقبل
توجه الى الناصره الان
وجيفارا البديري
الجبهه الديمقراطيه للسلام والمساواه
والحركه العربيه للتغيير اربعه مقاعد
وفققه نتائج العينات التلفزيونيه التجمع
الوطني لم نعرف ماذا سيحدث له بعد القائمه
العربيه الموحده منصور عباس اربعه مقاعد
هل هنالك اي مفاجاه هنا
قبل قليل الايمن عوده رئيس قائمه
الديمقراطيه للسلام
والمساواه والحركه العربيه
للتغيير فورا ظهور العينه الاولى العينه
التلفزيون رغم الخشيه منذ ساعات الصباح
ووفق استطلاعات الراي بان لا تصل الاحزاب
والقوائم العربيه الى عتبه همم
للوصول الى البرلمان الا انا بالفعل الان
وفق هذه الاستطاعات الاوليه على الاقل
نستطيع تاكيد وفقه هذه النتائج بان الجبهه
والحركه العربيه للتغيير وايضا القائمه
العربيه الموحده عبرته نتيجه الحزم ولكن
ما قاله ايمن عوده انه بعد شكري بالطبع
لكل المصوتين الذين نبوا النداء للوقوف في
وجه ما وصفها همم اليمنيه
اسرائيل الا انه طالب الجميع بالانتظار
حتى صدور النتائج الرسميه النهائيه هنا
كان يتوقع ان يكون الالاف او لم يكن
المئات من عناصر الحزبين ولكن كما لا نرى
لا يوجد مظاهر احتفال فعليه رغم ان
التوقعات كان بسبب بطبع زين انا توقعات
كانت ان لا تعبر اي من الاحزاب والقوائم
الانتخابات ولكن يبدو ان الساعتين
الاخيرتين في همم قبل اغلاق صناديق
الاختراع قلبتا المشهد ولكن مع ذلك ووفق
ما اكده ايمن عوده وايضا منصور عباس بانه
يجب على الجميع ان ينتظر ماذا سيحدث حتى
صدور النتائج النهائيه منصور عباس رئيس
القائمه الموحده الذي هو اصلا كان في
الاتلاف الحكومي مع حكومه لفيذ قال
قبل حوالي الساعه عندما كنا في مقر
القائمه بانه همم عندما كان يعتقد وهكذا
قول انه عندما كان في الائتلاف الحكومي لم
يكن هناك حرب على غزه لم يكن هناك
اعتداءات وانتهاكات بينما عند من فرط
العقد الحكومي همم انتهت غزه العدوان على
غزه همم يحدث في الضفه الغربيه ولكن على
الارض ووافقه الاستقلال يعني العينات
الكثيره
فلسطينيين الذين قابلناهم منذ يوم امس حتى
الان يقولون لا فرقه فعل بين اليمين
واليسار ليصل لبعض ويقول لنا من قتل شيرين
ابو عاقله ولكن الان كانت الخشيه في
ساعتين
عندما بدا الحديث عن ان اثمار بني كبير
الى نسب اعلى وايضا الخشيه بالنسبه
التصويت العالي جدا لدى المستوطنين ان
يصوت عدد كبير من افراد الجيش الاسرائيلي
لليمين المتطرف الذين يصفون هنا باليمين
الفاشل بعض المراقبين هنا يرون ان اسرائيل
الان انتقلت الى مرحله جديده الخشيه من كل
القوانين العنصريه وكما ذكرت نجوان من ان
تكون هناك الان ان يكون وزير للداخليه همم
او وزير امن داخلي اثمار بين كبير معناه
شراسه اكبر ضد الفلسطينيين على جانبي الخط
الخط والخوف ما هو قاده ولكن ساقول لك فقط
شيء اخر رد فعل فلسطين
نعم فيما يتعلق بالتجمع لانه فورا ظهور
نتائج العينات التلفزيونيه لم يكن هنالك
يقين بشان التجمع هل هنالك ما يشير الى
انه تجاوز ام لم يتجاوز العتبه الانتخابيه
الوصول الى عتبه الحسم ولكن هو قال لننتظر
ماذا سيحدث في الساعات القادمه ولكن الرد
الفعل الفلسطيني الاول كان من الدكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي ورئيس المبادره الوطنيه في
داخل الاراضي الفلسطينيه يقول ان نتائج
الانتخابات الاسرائيليه تظهر ان اسرائيل
انتقلت من التطرف العنصر الى الاجرام
العنصري والصعود الفاشيه حسب وصفه وهنا
عدد من المراقبين يشبهون الان اسرائيل بما
يحدث في عدد من الدول الاوروبيه والصعود
اليمين الاكثر تطرف
مدير المتحول مره اخرى الى الياس كرم
سريعا ايه وهنالك معلومات فيما يتعلق باثر
نتيجه التجمع على اليمين الاسرائيلي الياس
بالفعل وحزب التجمع الوطني الديمقراطي
قريب جدا بالنسبه الحسن وحسب النتائج
العينات المتوفره حاليا ويقف على ثلاثه
بالمئه اي قريب جدا من عتى العتبه
الانتخابيه التي تقف على ثلاثه وربع
بالمئه في حين ان الجبهه الديمقراطيه
للسلامه والسواق التجاوزت بنسبه قليله جدا
العتبه الانتخابيه هذا يعني انه ربما
يتمكن التجمع من ان يدخل ويجتاز العتبه
الانتخابيه ويسقط بالتالي
الجبهه والعربيه ل همم التغيير او ان يلجا
او تنجح كل الاحزاب العربيه في تخطي
العتبه الانتخابيه واذا ما نجحت بالفعل كل
الاحزاب العربيه في تخطي العتبه
الانتخابيه هذا سيكون بالتاكيد على حساب
همم كتله معسكر اليمين وهذا قد يريد
اليمين وستين فقط
لا انا تتحدث
هنالك ساعتين من التصويت
مره اخرى الى وليد العمري
الى وليد العمري
والحديث عن هذه العينات تحديدا واليه ماذا
هي تطابق النتائج التي تعلن وفق همم
الانتخابات الكثيره الماضيه هل هل كان
هنالك خطا في هذه العينات مثلا
اذا كانت ستخطئ ستخطئ بمقعد او اثنين لكن
نحن نتحدث عن ثلاث عينات انتخابيه كل منها
كان نحو 70 صندوق انتخاب وضعت في مراكز
اقتراع وطلب في كل منها من المنتخبين ان
يدنو بنفس التصويت في هذه الصناديق بمعنى
ان هناك الاف كثيرين قد شاركوا فيها ونحن
نتحدث عن ثلاث عينات اعطت تقريبا نتائج
متشابهه معسكر نتنياهو الذي يضم اللكود
والصهيونيه الدينيه وشاس ويهدودها مجتمع
من بين واحد و 60 مقعدا بمعنى انه يتجاوز
النصف المطلوب او الاغلبيه المطلوبه من
120 عضو تشكيل الائتلاف الحكومي المقبل
بينما المعسكر المحسوب على يمين الوسط
والوسط واليسار والقائمه العربيه الموحده
والذي يتزحمه همم
زعيم يوجد مستقبل وكذلك بين الجهاز حصل
مجتمعا على 54 الاربعه
المقاعد القائمه العربيه الموحده
والجبهه العربي الجبهه الديمقراطيه للسلام
والمساواه العربيه للتغيير اربعه بمعنى ان
هناك 120 مقعدا هي 62 لمعسكر نتنياهو 54
لمعسكر لبيد الذي يضم يوجد مستقبل
والمعسكر الرسمي واسرائيل بيتنا والعمل
ومارس والقائمه العربيه الموحده وهناك
اربعه مقاعد مع الجبهه العربيه للتغيير
هذه العينات على الاغلب ان تطابق او تكون
قريبه جدا من النتيجه النهائيه لان ما
يقوم بها هي معاهد قياس للراي ومعاهد
متخصصه ولكنها تعمل بالتعاون مع قنوات
التلفزه الرئيسيه الثلاث القنوات 12
وبما معناه نحن امام عينه او نموذجا
انتخابيه قد يطابق النتيجه النهائيه الا
اذا حصل بعض التغيرات على كل حال هم اصدر
وهذه النتائج في العاشره التوقيت المحلي
وسيتم تحديثها في العاشره والنصف فقد يكون
هناك مثلا هذه العينات اشارت الى ان
القائم التجمع الوطني الديمقراطي على حافه
تجاوز نسبه الحزم قد تشير الى العوده
ان يكون هناك بعض الاحزاب نعم عتبه
البرلمانيه عتبه البرلمان
ربما يعود اليك في همم بعد قليل حينما
تظهر همم يظهر تحديث لهذه نتائج ربما تكون
نتائج العينات النهائيه بعد اغلاق
الصناديق شامله همم الساعتين الاخيره لكن
همم اشكر وليد العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره
في القدس في فلسطين واشكر الياس كران من
مقر حزب الكود ونجوى من مقر حزب يوجد
مستقبله وجباره البديري من الجليل في شمال
فلسطين ارحب بضيفيه هنا في الاستديو همم
الدكتور سليم بريكه المختص في الشؤون
الفرقه اللبنانيه والحزبيه اهلا بك
والسيدات اورلي الناشطه السياسيه والكاتبه
الصحفيه وابدا بك همم سيده اورلي قراءته
لهذه النتائج او العينات الدقيقه
التسفون
نتائج النهائيه لكن بالنسبه للمعلومات
التي لدينا الان يبدو ان
نتنياهو وحلفه سيتمكن من
62 مقعدنا الذي يحتاجها لتشكيل الحكومه
لكن في سياقات اخرى قد يكون هذه هي فقط
البدايه لمشاكل نتنياهو بالاعتمادي على
مثلا
ربما الشخص الثاني او الثالث او اكثر قوه
في الحكومه التاليه لان
يجعلنا سهله
سوق المحاور همم
من اجل ان يؤمن المقاعد التي يحتاجها لكن
نعتقد ان نتنياهو يرغب بتقويه
اكثر ما هو عليه الان لان المقاعد الاولى
التي يبحث عنها بنفير بعد ذلك هي قاعده
الامر سيمثل
ربما معركه معقده للقوه بين
شخصين علينا ان نتذكر انه ايضا
همم
رئيس
هو هو
لديه
للطفل الغربيه
وهو يريد ان يحول النظام الفاصل عنصري
ويجعله نظاما رسميا لا اعتقد ان هذا شيء
يرغب به نتنياه هو لم يقم بضم ضفه الغربيه
خلال سنوات الطويله التي كان يحكم فيها
بوجود الموقف جديد
مناطق اخرى
ويتخذ اجراءات متطرفه
بالقيام بها قد تكون هذه اخبار جيده
مؤقتانيه لكن المعرفه المعركه قد بدات
الان
لانها احزاب غير متكافئه لا في رؤاها ولا
في توجهاتها ولا في هيدروجياتها يعني
هنالك احزاب عنصريه بشكل واضح تدعو الى
طرد الفلسطينيين من كل فلسطين التاريخيه
دكتور سليم همم ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث لهذا
الائتلاف يعني صحيح قد يكون هذه النتائج
او النتائج العينات صحيحه وقد يحصل معسكر
نتنياهو على 62 وقعدا لكن هل هذه الحكومه
اذا اذا حدثت همم ضيفتنا تقول انها لن
تكون مريحه للثانيهاهم اولا همم
عينات وليست نتائجنا نهائيا ولكن هناك ما
يسمى ال- همم
ايه الاصوات التي تاتي من الجيش ومن
مؤسسات الامن
والدبلوماسيين التي عاده تعطي على الاقل
مقعد اضافي لنتنياهو والصهيونيه الدينيه
يعني نحن نتحدث عن حزب الصهيونيه الدنيا
حوالي 15 عرض وكنيسه الرحي يتفككوا بعد
الانتخابات
لحزبين حزب كبير وحزب اسمه همم في قراءتين
مهمين جدا هنا اولا هاي انتخابات
دراماتيكيه بكل مفهوم الكلمه الاول ان
حديث الترانسفير يتحول من هوامش الدوله
الى مركز اتخاذ القرارات في الدوله وهذا
امر خطير جدا جدا
القضيه الثانيه المهمه جدا همم باعتقادي
هنا انه همم تصرف احزاب اليسار التي كانت
عمليا تصرف غير مسؤول في في في الظروف
التي كانت حزب العمل
في هذه الانتخابات هو التجمع اذا فاز في
الانتخابات
فهو هذا ضد كل
الاعتبارات وكل التقديرات ولكنه اذا لم
يجتاز وهذا ما اعتقده انا فهو الذي نصب
بنيامين نتنياهو رئيسا لحكومه اسرائيل
واليمن المتطرف بحرق الاصوات التي ادت
عمليا لاعطاء هذه الاضافه لليمين
الاسرائيلي
طيب فيما يتعلق
بائتلاف نتنياهو المحتمل السيده اورلي
نووي همم ما المخاطر ما هي النقاط التي
يمكن ان يتفكك عندها
امس
ما هي العقبه التي يمكن ان تؤدي الى تفكك
ائتلاف معسكر اقصى اليمين بقياده بنيام
الاول
في ان يكون موجود
دكتور سؤال هو قضيه
العدل وهذا شيء قد يؤدي الى توتر ربما
انحلال الى هذا التحالف
تصادم شخصيات وتصادم افكار لكن هنالك ايضا
سريع مناصب يمكن ان يكون السبب الذي يؤدي
الى تفكر هذه الحكومه لكن من من الشركاء
الاخرون الذين يمكن ان يصل اليهم اذا لم
يكن يريد تحالف الصهيونيه الدينيه ان يكون
في حكومته لا توجد
صراحه اكثر من مره والزم نفسه انه لا يمكن
وبالمناسبه
الماضي
لا يمكن ان يعود اليه بعد كل التصريحات
وانا سمعت اليوم اذا صار يجدد لان هذا غير
وارد نهائيا فما بقي امام نتنياهو ان يخضع
في البدايه انه لن يعيب من الداخل
انا اقرر النساء
للحكومه القادمه بقياده نتناوي يحرك شيء
واحد فقط تخليص نتنياهو من المحاكمات هو
يريد ان يعين وزير همم
عدل الذي يغير بعض القوانين وربما يسنوا
قوانين مثل قانون مثلا انتخاب المباشر
لرئيس الحكومه انا اعتقد ايضا انه القائمه
الموحد قد تتعامل معنى تنياهو بصفقات
معينه هذا ليس بالضروره ان تدخل الى
الائتلاف ولكن كان في الماضي حديث عن صفقه
التي من خلالها يغير قانون اساس الحكومه
وينتخب رئيس الحكومه بشكل مباشر وهذا طبعا
سيضعف اولا الاقليات مثل الاقليه العربيه
على سبيل المثال ومن الناحيه الثانيه
سيكررس حكم اليمين اوروبا من حكم نتنيه
نفسه بعد ابطال المحاكمات اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا دكتور سليم بريكه المختص في الشؤون
البرلمانيه والحزبيه وعشر ضيفه ايضا
النشاط السياسيه
شكرا جزيلا لكما همم نعود الى حسن في
الدوحه حسن ربما يكون العنوان الاكبر في
هذه الانتخابات انها جاءت بالحسم على غير
المتوقع
وفقا نتائج العينات غير النهائيه وانها
ايضا جعلت اليمين العنصري
الاستئصال في المركز الثالث في هذه
الانتخابات بعدما كان في الهواء اليك حسن
شكرا لك زين العابدين وسنبقى معك طبعا
لمتابعه اخر المستجدات خصوصا مع بدء صدور
النتائج الرسميه ليس فقط نتائج العينات
التي بدات تظهر ثور انتهاء او اغلاق
صناديق الاقتراع شكرا جزيلا لك ولكل طاقه
الجزيره